I am detective lieutenant Elliot and
this is trooper Wagner we just want to
ask a few questions
we understand none of his demise the
family have gathered to celebrate your
father's 85th birthday how was it hello
the party pre my dad's death it was
great
[Music]
congratulations on the film so the film
opens and closes with a mug that says my
house my coffee my rules
what is your strange house rule that
[ __ ]
no [ __ ] um rules you know we don't
smoke sorry you know I just I like as
soon as you know and there's nothing
worse than a reformed smoker there's
probably nothing worse than a reformed
drinker this is because I but I have
alcohol in my house easily but smoking I
just don't I'm probably my rule is
probably have about Phillip yes which is
interesting because your character he
smokes I know I hadn't smoked in a long
time Wow
did you actually smoke I did Daniel your
southern accent is so good in this film
and you also did one for Logan lucky so
how easily does this southern accent
come to you not easily and not and no
accent comes to me easily at all I wish
they did I'm a terrible mimic I was just
talking to someone the other day about
it and so saying if I do impressions of
people they just all sound like the same
person it's like I don't have it so I
have to I have to really work at it it's
like kind of learning a song or
something you have to kind of just I
have to kind of just bash away at it for
months on end before and then when I
when it when it's in it's in and then I
can just do it and I can say anything it
and that has to be it has to be like
that I can't sort of I can't put it on
was the accent your idea Orion
it's his script it's in the script yeah
it's in the script I mean it was - he
described him and and the way the
scripts written he's written as this the
eloquent Southern gentleman someone is
used to oratory who's used to who's used
to speaking likes the sound of his own
voice who speaks his thoughts to get his
head together so it was just there
so I just you know I filled in the gaps
so when you saw the script were you
excited at the possibility of doing
another voice other than James Bond
I was excited about doing the script
it's like it's such it's so beautifully
written and and so much fun and I barely
laughed when I read it the first time
and barely loved when I read it the
second time I mean it's it's it's that
kind of it's that and you know I'm just
we're saying you know one of the big
satisfying things for me a watching you
in front with an audience because it's
one of those movies that it just it
screams to going to be seen by in a
movie theater and that people got the
gags and they got every gag I mean they
get every gang you say every gang ever
eats you know every character has and
you're just satisfying
so I belly laughter watching the both of
you Jamie was it hard to keep a straight
face on scene when you were doing your
monologue specifically going through all
the details of the mystery well it's not
doing a straight face because he's
telling a story you know he's a
storyteller I mean really what a
detective who's working out ideas in his
head he's telling all of us a story and
so and his sort of malarial mellifluous
moleculus hmm help me mellifluous voice
this ha need whiskey huh need delicious
molasses voice is is compelling so I
wouldn't say that what he was saying was
funny in that moment because he's
telling the story jr. and I mean so it's
not it's hard to keep a straight face
around Michael Shannon period like
anything he does script it even if you
know what's coming that's he does it in
a weird way that makes you laugh so
great really quick you compare the
mystery to the center of a donut if you
guys were a donut what donut would you
be and why
I'm just glazed I'm old-fashioned
there's an old-fashioned donut oh it has
more rough edges kind of glaze but it's
it's an it glazed it's sort of that
shiny thing it's all sticky
old-fashioned are are they look like
crowns they kind of have little edges
and they're a little crispier
up your ass
oh very nice back Lee [ __ ] [ __ ]
definitely eat [ __ ] so the film
obviously opens up and closes with the
mud but says my house my coffee my rules
so what is your strange house rule my
personal ass of the house I grew up in
your personal health my personal house I
don't have many rules and there there's
no rules or the one you grew up in uh
shoes off it's not that uncommon oh my
gosh I don't know no not really
come as you are yeah I guess my
childhood undimmed yeah I guess it was
like that just come back when you're
hungry some beans yeah both your
characters are heavily involved in the
narrative of this film so were you guys
given the whole script and did you know
what the ending was yeah yeah what was
it like getting the whole script of the
film
uh Wow typically you get the whole
script but but it was it was certainly a
fun read you know it's one of those
movies that you burned through because
you don't really know who who did it it
was a real page-turner I mean I was
guessing until the very end
yeah likewise I mean it was a very
original and surprising and exciting and
I obviously right away filling up with
my character and that was my good name
to do this please yeah I love the
character martyrs so much and the family
in the movie misidentifies you know your
characters culture so much and we never
really get to find out where Marta's
from so did you develop a cultural
background for your character prepping
for this um and the actors is who played
my mom and sister we're actually Cuban
like me so I think we went with it
we just didn't want to get into like
getting like actually saying in the
movie where she was from because Cuban
that you guys have very specific rule
and laws for immigration and that would
have complicated the whole the whole
thing so I think the end of the day I
think it was intentional actually not
saying where she was from and let just
you know leave people still guessing
where she you know Christ I have to ask
you know everyone's probably asked you
today but what was it like telling
everyone to eat [ __ ] it's great it's
really satisfying I think it's a very
appropriate statement you know I mean
like it really kind of is uh I was gonna
say it's very cutting yeah who said I'm
initially the line was f off but but we
didn't want to make it an r-rated movie
and I have a friend that used to say eat
my [ __ ] eat my [ __ ] and I always thought
it was such a funny thing to say I'm
gonna do that I was waiting
but yeah yeah eat [ __ ] just felt right
can I say he chose to lay down seven
times I think what by that when he says
that we're all so happy to tell them
these family eats [ __ ] that we is the
first time I think we like thank you I'm
buddy said hey what was your go to
insult growing up um probably f off you
know yeah yeah cuz it's got it you know
for a Boston accent if off you can
really drag that off I would like to
request that you all state until the
investigation is completed
what can we ask why has something
changed no no it hasn't changed or no we
can't ask congratulations on the film
the film opens and starts with a mug
that says my house my coffee my rolls
done what is your strange house world my
strange house rule I have very few rules
in my house don't lie I do what you say
you're gonna do don't if you make a
mistake fix it and don't speak unless
it's funny Wow does anyone get punished
if they say something that's not funny
no those are the rules you just stick to
the roads you don't get punished you are
just point to the rules I say oh no see
that's rule number three right there you
got it
don't talk anymore yeah you're not funny
see right there it says roll number four
you got to be funny I love it I would
not want to do in your house you
obviously played an iconic detective in
Miami Vice so did you give these guys
any pointers on how to play a cool suave
detective oh no no no they don't need me
help you know they're there they're
pretty capable did you feel like the
detective come outing you during this
one no because I was so I loved playing
this sort of do-nothing sort of CAD that
you know kept man that I was having a
blast of that was it hard to keep a
straight face during some of the scenes
really hard you know what who had the
most difficult time was Ryan Johnson
director we'd be in the middle of the
scenes that you'd be standing by the
camera just cackling just giggling with
you I'm sorry guys we're gonna do it
again okay made me laughing speaking of
detectives Daniel Craig's character
refers to the mystery as the center of a
donut oh yeah let's not ruin it for
people because that speech is fantastic
it's so unreal but if you were a donut
on what donut would you be in one place
baby why I I I like it straight and real
and sweet you have like well thought-out
answers for everything House Rules the
donut yeah
there you go I kept it around a while
I've had time to think about this family
is truly desperate when people get
desperate the nerves come out this is a
twisted web so the film starts and ends
with this mug that says my house my
coffee my rules so I want to know what
are your strange house rules oh my
mother's half Korean quarter Korean
seven oh she's in the house just be
clean that's not unusual but that's very
important yeah yeah I know
no I was gonna say the same I just spent
I spent the last year living in Europe
and it's you take off your coat you take
off your shoes
but then some other places that I've
grown up in it's like you don't take off
your shoes so I'm like okay now I'm
whatever I take them off I didn't take
them off yeah I guess I don't know I
guess the defense where you live or
where you do you guys had to come up
with a strange house you have to pee
outside there's no can't use the
bathroom that's where my mind remember
when cuz I kinda have to use bathroom
right now okay you're gonna be we're not
gonna make you go outside I'm gonna get
ya thank you I feel like I have a lot of
creative friends so if I had a house
rule I'd be like please leave something
or like draw something or something like
that because I'm much better handsome
other night I don't I haven't like I've
lived out of bags the last three years
so to have a home and somewhere it's
like in one place is a real dream but
like I've learned that like your home
and your your yeah your home is where
your friends are and where people you
love are so that having little pieces of
your friends is not no actual pieces of
your friends but like that's beautiful
one of my favorite parts in the film is
when Daniel Craig's character compares a
mystery to the center of a donut so if
you guys were a donut what donut would
you be in life Wow
hard-hitting questions I love this I
wish I had like some people are really
clever with their answers and like I and
I think I'm just gonna be ridiculous but
what would you say
Oh God well we took that BuzzFeed that
test yesterday where you had to pick it
pick a doughnut to see if you were
guilty or or whether you would survive
it the dinner party yeah and my theory
was that if you picked jelly doughnut it
represented blood and death
is I represent blood content I feel like
I'd go original but I'd want like an
original doughnut but like just because
it's no but like a stable consist I
don't maybe this an aspiration to be
just like a consistently Pleasant or not
but then like put like a sparkler in it
so it's a bit of more of a surprise yeah
a little bit different
there is one kill sivanna in the hand
and all you know something
oh my god tell me what happened to my
granddaughter
it ask you about Marta's character
because she does something really weird
and funny when she lies you know how did
you come up with us so Marta the
character and part of the Ana de Armas
plays she can't lie otherwise she will
puke so it's kind of like a story thing
that I had where as she sees her
character is in a really tough position
and the only way to get out of that is
by lying and something I learned from
Vince Gilligan you want to make life as
hard as possible for your characters if
you're a writer and so giving her this
unmissable very splashy thing where you
can't miss it everyone's going to know
she tells a lie that seemed like a like
a good thing to do how did you go about
giving out the script Ryan did you just
give certain cast members their lines to
keep everyone guessing or did you give
out the whole script I gave the whole
script to everyone I'm a very trusting
person yes maybe I was like yeah no but
I felt like everybody kind of needed to
know the entire thing coming into it so
they knew how their part fit in so I
didn't do any games where I like held
anything back I was just like no this is
a story we're all telling let's let's
have fun and do this so nice and you can
tell everyone's having fun and doing
that's one of the things I'm really
happy about with them but I feel like
you really can tell how much fun
everybody's having on screen and that
that's a real reflection of how I felt
on set and got Daniel Craig you can
really tell how much fun he said nothing
loose yeah I was talking to him he was
saying that you actually wrote the
accent into the script so did you
envision you know how he was gonna come
out with that accent while you were
writing the role no I wrote southern
accents just kind of vaguely thinking
well he'll be a fish out of water
amongst all these rich New Englanders
and then Daniel and I collaborated to
figure out what the accent would
actually because southern accent there's
so many variations so many things that
could be and we landed on like a
Mississippi accent that's very kind of
honey this sort of plate pleasing to
listen to basically was what we were
going for kind of foghorn leghorn a
little bit did you were there any
inspirations for that yeah he actually
he found we discussed there's this
historian Shelby Foote who was in Ken
Burns's Civil War documentary
and a lot and he has that exact
Mississippi accent in a very low
register and it's just the most pleasing
thing to Lee it's great to put on to
fall asleep too because it's just it's
like a lullaby it lulls you to sleep
another thing you notice while watching
this film is the sets are so beautiful
and intricate like the one we're sitting
in now yeah do you have a favorite
hidden detail and if so what is the
meaning by are so many things I mean
even just looking this is actually like
this is the real said that like a
picture of the real set that we were we
were on and I was just staring at the
books on the shelves everyone I love the
main character or one of the main
characters Christopher Plummers
character is a mystery writer and we
created all these fake books and as
someone who's in grew up loving murder
mystery books creating all these fake
titles and book covers if you can pause
the movie when you get it on home video
and read all the titles we had fun
you